our Kim Kardashian and Geoffrey star in
a social-media war it's such a trip okay
here's what's going on between the
beauty bosses I'm never not proud of
anything that I have shared you know Kim
was showing off some of her new k'kaw
products on Instagram shimmer you guys
have no idea this formula how smooth it
is
and Geoffrey was a little confused by
them posting some tweets critiquing the
way Kim was showing off her palette
calling her swatches rough big shocker
Kim's fans went after Geoffrey for
posting the tweets but then him stepped
in yes she actually thanked the digital
star for his criticism thank I welcome
honest you know comments about my
products and you
cuz of it I'm just watching butter now
so so everyone get off his ass and let's
not be so negative we're all in this
together there's room for all of us love
you Jeffrey that's what a boss ass [ __ ]
does she learns from her mistakes and
she keeps it moving but all the internet
trolls and all these psycho people want
to run their guns and turn it into a
circus it's makeup